you're going in you know in a game like
this I'm talking to Billy Bean who's in
baseball okay this Billy Bean is you
know Moneyball right so I'm asking I
said listen when you're recruiting and
you're looking for these next Superstars
what are some things you look at he says
one is obviously the real talent the
other one is the guy's work ethic the
other one is their upbringing family
roots and then you know there was one
other thing that he said that he added
to those one to four things
and I said what's the most important
thing and he kind of broke it down we
went through it because you know
on-based percentage what's the most
important thing when recruiting people
in your world if you were to say to make
it in Hollywood as competitive as it is
as you know it's a very sensitive it's
artists competing sensitivity you got
this person how come I didn't get that
job this person didn't get that job then
they're going to remember you took that
role away from me they're gonna talk
behind your back because you like I can
only imagine how competitive this
business can be it's more vicious what
are some qualities you need to be able
to make it for all these years
well let me start by saying you know I
have a daughter that's 15 months old and
and you know my girlfriend and I joke
around about the acting thing and I
literally say it's never gonna happen
until she's 18 she makes that decision
but as a child actor I wouldn't wish it
on my worst enemy now I was fortunate
enough to wear I don't know how but it
is it is dangerous and and and the
social media component that exists now
that didn't exist 10 years ago or even
when you know Entourage was
social media was just becoming a thing
but I think that adds a degree of of
danger you know for for young people
um it's just I I looked at
how uh Justin Bieber and how what some
of these people's lives must be like
trying to navigate that world of just
going to the grocery store and and you
know and social media has complicated it
a lot
um I know that Hollywood has has come a
long way in protecting uh kids on set
last night for example we're you know
again it's late and um there was a young
actress on set and at the at the minute
it was like the referee stepped in and
this is this is a big it's a big
production this woman comes in like that
she was just gone yanked her not one
more take not anything just that's it
time's up so the laws of protecting the
kids have have come a long way so
they've made a lot of progress on that
oh my goodness I was last night I was
like whoa that kid just got snatched off
the set crazy you know back you know
back in the day they would be like all
right well you know we'll give you you
speed it along we'll give you 10 more
minutes now it's
lights out but I guess more my question
is okay so longevity is it Biz depth
meaning relationship is it shaking hands
is it choosing the right support team is
it constantly being a student going to I
don't know Aaron Spicer you're
constantly taking different acting
classes learning different styles is it
you know a person that sets the ego
aside is it somebody that knows how to
manage your egos is it what are some
things that you I mean you You're great
friends with Leo you've done stuff with
you and Toby Leo there's a bunch of
history with what you guys have done
there is there's a not many people you
haven't worked with you work with a lot
of people in the industry you've been
around the other night we're having
dinner I don't know where we were having
dinner we're having dinner at uh catch
State we catch yeah that's good
phenomenal food by the way blown away
we're just sitting there having dinner
and all of a sudden Jamie Foxx shows up
Jimmy comes up to our table hey what's
up Kevin but Jamie sits right behind us
everybody knows who you are you're in a
world with a lot of folks that the the
the rest of the world watches and I
cannot believe this guy's in it
what are some things that allow you to
be staying relevant for three four
decades in the industry
um yeah I mean listen the one thing
about the entertainment industry that
it's 99 percent
maybe more rejection right so usually
the answer is no right if the odds of an
actor getting a role are very are very
slim so once you sort of toughen up to
it I think it sort of spills out into
other parts of your personality right
where you know
um like I you know we we never needed
participation trophies like as a kid
right like yeah you finished in fifth
place like what do you want to say
it never bothered me I was like oh I I
didn't get four auditions this week I
think I'm mad that we finished fifth
place in field day who cares
um but you do you you kind of you kind
of you kind of toughen up to it um and
again I you know I've always
for me and I don't want to say it's not
necessarily stalled but whenever there
would be I would I would I was always
quick to Pivot right so if something was
going on and acting was a little slow I
would say hey let's go make a short film
you know I'll direct it you write it or
this all right I'll act in it you
produce it you just would always keep it
moving and then then all of a sudden
Once you turn down this road the other
people you know then the acting jobs go
back so it's really just for me it's
always just like staying active and and
keeping it moving and and just trying to
figure out a way to to compete you know
which we talk about like the podcast
space and and which is you know what
I've gotten into over the last couple of
years
Hollywood is they're just so many
Gorillas right to to compete with some
of these Studios I mean it's impossible
I mean if you know any good book or it's
sold before it's a book right if you
pick up a book in the bookstore you're
like wow this is amazing that book's
long gone right it was sold when it was
a manuscript right so one of the things
that I've had the idea about podcasting
is hey this is a way that I can create
IP and and have ownership of of my own
stuff and not have to
compete with with you know the big
studios that have like Deepak
[Music]